de plus en plus d'agriculteurs sont aux
prises avec des mauvaises herbes qui
survivent aux herbicides pour se
débarrasser de ces plantes qui poussent
au mauvais endroit ils doivent utiliser
des produits souvent plus chers et plus
toxiques et vous allez le voir une
invention créé pour faciliter le
désherbage chimique a désormais des
effets pervers auchan
la floraison h heure on voit les slicks
au centre du québec l'histoire de la
firme shivani semblent de prime abord
classique ici c'est la moutarde des
oiseaux qui survit aux arrosages
d'herbicides avec les années le rond qui
avait mettons un petit rond de vérifier
mais avec les récoltes mais ça ça se met
avec la bateau
envoyé les ronces agrandi
la moutarde des oiseaux une plante
sauvage est une proche parente d'une
autre plante abondamment cultivé au
canada le canola au milieu des années 90
la compagnie monsanto obtient le feu
vert pour commercialiser du canola
transgénique au canada cette plante a
été modifié génétiquement pour tolérer
les arrosages d'herbicides à base de
glyphosate
quand on pulvérise le produit toutes les
mauvaises herbes moeurs et le canola lui
survit aujourd'hui la quasi-totalité du
canola canadien est transgénique et ces
jeunes ne connaissent pas de frontières
en 2010 certes on a envoyé pour la
première fois le des feuilles de
moutarde pour faire le test génétique
pour vérifier c'était quoi cette plante
l'eau c'est l'eau qui ont découvert que
la plante était étaient résistantes au
glyphosate non pas une résistance qui se
développe par une mauvaise utilisation
en utilisation répétée d'un produit mais
bien un jeune qui était dans le canot
look se transférer dans la moutarde des
oiseaux fax et comme une mauvaise herbe
ogm ont voté comme les deux plantes sont
très similaires le canola génétiquement
modifiés peut facilement polliniser la
moutarde des oiseaux il en résulte un
hybride fertile qui même s'ils se
recroisent avec d'autres moutarde
conservera le gène de la résistance aux
herbicides
après un an seulement 8% des plans de
moutarde en bordure du champ
présenteront des jeunes de canola
transgénique la moutarde des oiseaux
génétiquement modifiés a été répertorié
pour la première fois au québec en 2005
dans la région de chaudière appalaches
aujourd'hui 30 populations sont connus
surtout au centre du québec une région
où l'on cultive pourtant peu de canola
même des producteurs qui n'ont jamais
soumis cette culture se retrouve avec ce
transgene chez eux la moutarde après la
place de soyaux salle étoffe les plains
quand ça souffle un peu moins - le
lendemain ou ce que les partitions sont
affectés c'est bien qu'ils soient de
fait ou si on a des images d'un chien
qui a des lignes avec un peu de guitare
mais imaginez ce même champ à l'eau ces
raids la moutarde comme ça sur toute la
grandeur du chien bleu ça occasionne des
méchantes perte d'aura
une question se pose donc qui est
responsable de la transmission de ces
jeunes d'une culture commerciale vers
une plante sauvage il ya quelques années
monsanto a défendu jusqu'en cour suprême
la propriété intellectuelle des gènes de
tolérance au glyphosate qu'on retrouve
dans le canola génétiquement modifiée
en 2004 le plus haut tribunal du pays a
donné raison à monsanto dans sa bataille
contre un agriculteur de la saskatchewan
le géant de l'agrochimie accusait percy
schmeiser infirmiers d'avoir fait
pousser du canola transgénique sans
avoir payé les redevances liées à
l'utilisation des semences
petit schmeiser a toujours soutenu que
ces chants avait été accidentellement
contaminés entre autres par du pollen de
canola génétiquement modifiés transporté
par le vent très volatile ce pollen peut
voyager sur des kilomètres aujourd'hui
alors que ces mêmes jeunes se retrouvent
dans des plantes qui nuisent aux
agriculteurs on peut se demander sont
ils toujours la propriété du fabriquant
meyer qui a acquis monsanto n'a pas
répondu à notre question mais il a
invité les agriculteurs aux prises avec
le problème à les contacter
pour contourner le problème de la
résistance l'industrie propose depuis
quelques années de nouvelles semences
génétiquement modifiées pour tolérer
plus qu un herbicide cette technique
s'appelle l'empilement de gênes on voit
donc des cultures qui tolèrent à la fois
le glyphosate par exemple et d'autres
herbicides beaucoup plus toxiques comme
le dit kamba ou encore le 2,4 d un
composé de l'agent orange utilisé comme
défoliant lors de la guerre du vietnam
mais développer ces nouvelles semences
peut prendre dix ans et certaines
mauvaises herbes sont déjà résistantes à
ce cocktail au bout de cinq ans à peine
à ce rythme la partie est perdue
d'avancé
la solution serait donc ailleurs entre
autres dans une agriculture plus
diversifiée c'est ce que
j'essaye toujours d'encourager les
producteurs afin d'aider bonne rotation
était gris les céréales dans la rotation
depuis des années les céréales ont été
remplacés dans bien des chants par du
maïs et du soya cultivées en alternance
deux plantes qui rapporte plus à court
terme mais ces monocultures ne valent
pas les céréales pour damer le pion aux
mauvaises herbes
la céréale souvent avoir mis une
température assez bas aux autres à
l'entendre son développement rapidement
ce qui fait qu'à vaut couvrir le sol
aussi rapidement donc très compétitive
contre les mauvaises herbes ce qui fait
que elle laisse pas la chance aux
mauvaises herbes de s'installer parce
que la lumière va pas dans le fond du
champ et les céréales ont l'avantagé
d'être récoltés plus tôt en saison que
le maïs et le soya canton les fauche on
fauche en même temps la mauvaise herbe
avant qu'elle ne puisse monter en graine
bon coupe l'herbe sous le pied des
mauvaises amont l'empêchent de se
multiplier mais dans les cultures maïs
soyaux on a des très longue saison de
végétation on est presque capable avant
la récolte de multiplier n'importe
quelle mauvaise heure mais dans les
serial on en élimine beaucoup
ne jamais laisser la voie libre aux
mauvaises herbes ça veut dire aussi
planter des cultures intercalaires entre
les rangs de maïs par exemple et des
cultures de couverture tout de suite
après une récolte
une autre solution mise de l'avant c'est
la culture du foin pour les animaux en
couvrant le sol ces plantes vivaces
laisse peu de place aux indésirables
sarr attendent énormément le
développement où l'expansion d'une
morgan l'instant et puis
en plus mon n'empêche la magasin de se
multiplier pendant ce temps là parce
qu'on fait des fautes à répétition
dans certains cas le retour du sarclage
mécanique sera nécessaire après tout
aucune plainte n'a démontré de
résistance au sarc leur et l'avenir nous
réserve peut-être aussi d'autres
solutions investir dans un robot des
apports version s'investir dans des
pesticides mais moi ça me dérange pas
d'investir dans leur goût d'un
désherbeur trépied est encore plus coté
environnementale sait mais il faut que
ce soit faut que ce soit mécanisée
robotisés je commence cette année depuis
qu'il est aussi d'être surpris que ça
prend que ça fonctionne pop 2 cpo pas
chose la plus agréable à faire non plus
aisés c'est pas du vieux d'autant humain
ne peut ni produits peur aux pics sur
l'autre bord les masses et tout écrit
pour freiner la résistance il faudra
aussi un changement de mentalité et des
postures actions qui sont très
allergique à la présence de mauvaises
herbes à ma donné il faut arrêter de
s'acharner pour tenir bon voire avoir un
champ propre parce que la nation
propreté en agriculture elle peut coûter
cher écologiquement pour déjouer ces
plantes à la formidable capacité
d'adaptation
on devra cesser de se fier uniquement
sur la chimie est resté constamment aux
aguets il faut pas oublier que
dépendamment de l'espèce de plantes
auxquels on a affaire
ils sont plus ou moins de guérir mais
ils font toujours beaucoup plus de grain
que les cultures qu'on récolte si on se
questionne pas sûr pourquoi il ya tel
type de magasin dans nos champs on s'y
intéresse pourront voir multiplier le
problème très très rapidement la lutte
intégrée elle commence par le dépistage
elle commence par la connaissance des
ennemis ce soit pour les magasins ou les
insectes ou les maladies il faut
connaître les champs faut savoir à qui
on a faim
[Musique]